if you're a ps4 user you know your
console of choice receives pretty
frequent updates I'm Tony and this
GameSpot news update is here to tell you
all about the latest one the ps4 is five
point five three update is live now but
honestly you might not even notice a
difference the patch note there's only
one says quote this system software
update improves system performance yeah
that's it
meanwhile European ps4 users recently
got an additional notice in the update
that mentions data collection and
requires you to opt in to having your
data shared before you can take your ps4
back online as we just learned the data
collection itself isn't new but the
agreement is Sony is simply complying
with the --use new gdpr laws that
require companies to be transparent
about their data collection so if you
want to go online information like what
you buy on PSN or what video apps you
used will have to be shared with Sony
and in the meantime you can always
follow our top stories like this through
the GameSpot now app on iOS or Android
[Music]